[Music]
don't be tardy
we are hitting the road this season i've
seen the first two episodes
it's no pun intended a wild ride from
the jump what is the wildest thing you
packed for this trip could you cram a
lot onto that bus
i think i packed my entire house i
packed everything i mean i brought
tons of my wigs we all had 40 outfits
each i shopped for everybody and they
all had 40 outfits
well the the glam was still on point
crammed into that little rv
what was it like to get ready in the in
the bus
i actually i was on steroids but now
looking back i'm like so puffy and so
swollen i'm glad i know i think we're
both looking back like my lips were huge
i was blonde i wasn't really
in my prime this season like i feel like
it was so long ago i look absolutely
nothing like that anymore thank god
um but doing the glam was
all we had was we had our makeup artist
that kind of traveled with us
um so that was really helpful but having
to do
our hair in some of the
koa bathrooms was a test because i'll be
curling my hair
and then there's like a huge like spider
spider right here and i'm like right
here and there's not really in many
places i can go and i'm not gonna leave
my curling iron here
so it was like you either have to like
toughen up
and act kind of like a dude for a second
and be like all right
finish the hair and get out as quick as
you can brielle you brought up
making the transition to brunette taking
the filler out of your lips why make
those choices
i think i just look back at some photos
of me and
i got to a point where i was like okay
you know the lips weren't going down
they say last like six months
i really did not get my lips redone
before i got them dissolved for like a
year and a half and it wasn't going down
like it wasn't dissolving
nothing was happening there were no
changes being made
um i think whatever it was because i had
a little too many chefs in the kitchen i
was definitely going to a few
um they should have just stuck with dr
from the very beginning
we would have been fine yes uh but since
i started going to him and some other
people on la and whatever when he was
busy and whatnot
um i found an incredible doctor in
atlanta i'm actually gonna go see on
saturday dr doan
um and i asked her you know
what do you think like should we take it
out and start over she's like yes you
don't even have a shape anymore like
let's just
dissolve it let's let's restart and she
has a more subtle natural approach
to the lips and of course my lips are
overdrawn a little bit here right now
but um yeah and the dark hair you know
i just want to differentiate myself i
want to be brielle biermann not
kim's daughter everywhere i go it's oh
my god you're kim's daughter oh my god
it's kim's daughter
i love her i'm like okay well what about
me you know i'm on the tv show you're
still getting
water we'll always be your that's okay
because i can go dark
so but you won't ever but like i can get
a wig and just start running around with
a dark wig
why don't you go do the next interview
in the wig well no because my bang i
have to do it's a whole process it's not
that easy sweet
i'm happy with where i'm at though like
i like my lips better a little smaller i
like my hair
darker um looking back at the episodes
that were filmed i like it a very long
time ago
um i'm like wow i really did look a
little crazy
so i don't think you guys ever look
crazy give me a number what's the daily
glam budget in this house because it has
to be
up there it's a lot now because you know
ariana was like my tomboy you know she
didn't want makeup she didn't want hair
she wore like umbro shorts and
you know sneakers and tank tops so now
she's like girly girl so we're all three
hair done makeup done
um i mean uh it's
it's a couple thousand dollars a day for
sure
wow that's not including outfits because
yeah that's not that's just makeup and
hair that's just the neck up
that's just the makeup and the styling
of the hair not the
wig itself or the clothes how about the
hair itself like i
i probably have about eight thousand
dollars worth of hair in my head right
now
oh my gosh you kim you did tell me at
bravocon which was right after
ariana had turned 18 i think that 18 was
when she could get her lips done did she
choose to do that or not
no ariana has not done her lips yet um
she talks about it she wants to do it
she'll probably go with her
she overdraws her lips i'm okay if she
was to go to you know dr dome but i
you know she overdraws her lips um
she's got a really big beautiful smile
so and she really loves her smile as
well so i don't know
if you talk to her she's gonna be like
this or the next you know hour
[Music]